that polar vortex that I was telling you
about is about to hit the state of Texas
and many other parts of the country
illegal immigrants sleeping outside an
already freezing temperatures
well that struggle is about to get worse
Texas governor Greg Abbott is right now
saying all that we do next on the border
is about saving lives urgently we're
having to manage the crisis on the
border regardless of what's happening
because even before the potential
lifting of title 42 we've seen this
massive influx but you've got to go back
to see the way that the Bible
ministration has handled this whole
situation completely unprepared complete
disaster and Texas is left to pick up
the pieces of the disaster cause by the
Biden Administration
Tom Hillman Fox News contributor former
acting ice director I have heard many
people say it in the lead up to this
week now I hear it a lot is this America
no it's not it's not America I grill pin
and You Begin your monologue you said
where's President Biden I agree with you
he hasn't made one trip to the Border
he's been to Arizona he can't make an
hour trip down to the border to talk to
the men and women that put their lives
on line for this country every day who
are overwhelmed to the to the point 14
of them have committed suicide this year
where's the commander-in-chief and to
add to that where's Congress now they're
looking at a funding bill that doesn't
address a crisis all the money in the
funding bill talks about giving millions
and more dollars to ngos to help process
and release more into United States when
you process quicker and release quicker
more are going to come so we send a
message to the whole world across the
board illegally you won't be detained
you be released and we'll get to the
Final Destination who the hell wouldn't
come to the greatest nation on Earth if
there's no consequence for entering
illegally and what upsets me the most
Harris is the death how many Americans
have to die from fentanyl overdoses
because 90 of the border patrol is no
longer on patrol how many migrants have
to die we got nearly 1500 migrants have
died a terrible tragic death because the
most vulnerable people in the world will
put themselves in hands of criminal
cartels to come across an open border
secure border saves the lines and
President Biden's policies are killing
people at record numbers
you heard the governor there and and the
urgency that I hear in your voice and
and now it's spreading to some on the
other side of the political aisle or at
least in the middle Kirsten Cinema that
senator who now suddenly is an
independent wants to take a bipartisan
group down to the Border these ideas are
good and great in some instances but it
is so late in this game to be talking
about show and tell
it is late because they released several
million people into the United States
even even if you know and right now if
you look at the court data Immigration
Court data nearly nine out of ten people
who claim Asylum at the border never get
relief from U.S courts but they simply
don't qualify so they can calm Asylum
Seekers but most of his fraudulent claim
to Asylum and they'll get an order
removal they lose their case in the
federal judges say You must leave the
country
you can't remove millions of people how
the hell are you going to do that so you
know the people need to understand these
millions of people coming across right
now
they're here to stay you know even even
the most proactive ice doesn't have the
resources to go arrest millions of
people people need and they're gonna
they're gonna lose their case they're
not going to leave and they're going to
hide out waiting for the next amnesty
because this country's showing over and
over again if you have you hide out long
enough we're going to give you a doctor
we'll give you an ambassy we'll give you
something all these family groups coming
across right now all these children a
quarter million children have entered
this country since Joe Biden become
president they're your next dock of
people they took advantage and said okay
maybe if I get to the country I can be
the next DACA recipient we have to
secure the border before we make any
promises on amnesty or anything else
secure the border and save lives stop
the flow
you are the expert
and one of many who we should be
listening to but instead here's what
Congress is doing the new Congressional
spending bill which is enormous you
talked about it for just a moment we're
going to dig in deeper gives DHS look at
that that's a big pot of cash
some 1.5 billion of that though is
restricted as operations and support
allocations that money quote cannot be
used to acquire maintain or extend
border security technology and
capabilities
former CBP Customs Border Protection
acting commissioner Mark Morgan called
the funding restriction
um
well he used a bad word bleeping
Insanity obviously and North Carolina
Republican Dan Bishop says those
priorities are America last in action so
we're going to spend a whole lot of cash
but we're not going to spend it where it
needs to be at the border
so I'll say this to any Republican that
votes for that bill any Republicans that
went down to the border and did a dog
and pony show and comes back to Congress
and signs that knowing there's no money
to secure that border there's only money
to bring more people in into process
them in and to release them into United
States they shouldn't be representing Us
in Congress you can't have both sides
how again I'll say it again how many
Americans have to die of fentanyl
overdoses how many migrants have to die
how many women need to be sexually
assaulted by the cartels how many women
and children need to be sex trafficked
across the U.S border which are at
record numbers now of women and children
being trafficked for sexual purposes
across the border at what point do the
congressmen Republican or Democrat
independent say enough's enough we got
to protect Americans we got to save
lives border you can have National
Security off border security they've
arrested 116 known as expected
terrorists trying to enter into the
country we got over 1 million known
gotaways recorded video how many of them
are known suspected terrorists at what
point does our national security in the
lives of Americans in the lives of
vulnerable migrants mean enough for them
to take action and secure this border
and spend some of that money to send to
Ukraine on our own border and protect
Americans
you know Tom Holman joining us now if
you are just tuning in we are getting
some really rich detail from you because
you know what it takes to make us safe
and much of that is not being done right
now and the game is about to change we
don't know what they're going to do with
title 42. it's it's like a literally a
game of hot potato up in Washington DC
well the U.S Supreme Court says one
thing the White House says this we're
waiting on on doj for this but they
could in the meantime use some of the
other laws that Obama used like title
eight there's plenty on a plate that we
could use to deport people at this point
Harris you're exactly they got title way
expedited removal but let's let's not
forget title 42 we already got a crisis
with title 42 in place right but what
about that's true what about we put what
about putting back to remain in Mexico
program which was a game changer for the
Trump Administration people can still
claim Asylum they're just going away to
Mexico to the hearing day that was a
game changer so the administration can
do that the courts haven't shut that
down so if they really want to secure
the Border if they really want to save
American lives from drug overdoses if
they really want to save migrant lives
if they care about these people dying in
the freezing weather in Texas why not
put the remaining Mexico program back in
place until Congress figures out how to
fix it because they want open borders
Joe Biden ran out open borders I see
this many times this is an incompetence
this isn't mismanagement this is by
Design he ran on open borders when you
say I don't put a more torment
deportations I'm going to shut down uh
iced detention facilities I'm going Ward
amnesty I'm going to give free medical
care when you make those types of
promises the most vulnerable people in
the world are going to put themselves in
hands of criminal cartels to be abused
and to die and to be sexually assaulted
this Administration can fix this in 30
days all they got to do is brush off the
Trump policies and re-implement them
Trump people will say our policies are
inhumane Tom Holmen president Trump you
guys are inhumane that Administration
let me tell you something from illegal
immigration was down 83 percent when 83
percent unless people are coming how
many women weren't being raped how many
Americans weren't dying from drug
overdoses because border Patrol's back
on the line how many migrants didn't die
I mean how many you know at what point
do do we do we do we do make Common
Sense decisions to save lives and
protect our national security you can't
have National Security at border
security we get all these databases in
place errors that we got the TSA
screening database so no flight list we
got the Visa security program they mean
nothing now don't put yourself don't try
to get a ticket or VISA just go to
Mexico and cross the border illegally
and get in and and not be caught that
scares the hell out of me your line of
the day you cannot have National
Security without border security and if
we are not safe we are not sovereign
period Tom Holman thank you very much
for getting us started on this topic and
being in Focus today appreciate your
time and expertise always
thanks for having me hey everyone I'm
Emily compagno catch me and my co-host
Harris Faulkner and Kaylee mcineny on
outnumbered every weekday at 12 p.m
Eastern or sets your DVR also don't
forget to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page for daily highlights